thanks for joining us America we are so
glad you're here
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
Ramsey solutions John and crystal or
hair hey guys how are ya
good awesome welcome it's so good to
have you where do you live Montana fun
welcome to Nashville that's a bit of a
haul yeah it's been a long drive down
there we've got about 3,200 miles so far
oh wow and with three kids yeah that's
kind of that's kind of doing 7,000 miles
pretty nice it's a multiple yeah it's a
multiplier yeah well welcome and you're
here to do your debt-free scream oh my
goodness wonderful how much you'll be
paid off
now we've paid off eighty seven thousand
dollars in about three and a half years
way to go man excellent making what kind
of money oh we started out around eighty
to ninety thousand and erupted about 130
cool what do you guys do for a living I
work out in the oil field up in the up
in the Bakken up in North Dakota okay a
lot of hours doing that huh oh yeah but
the money's good way to go cool so what
kind of debt was this eighty seven
thousand dollars crystal Oh most of it
was student loans mm-hmm credit card
mm-hmm and who student loans this guy's
up here this guy over here over me this
guy named John okay so what's your
degree in John well I guess I have an
associates in human biology mm-hm
that's kind of part of the story we I
did the prerequisites to go to a
chiropractic school and we actually
ended up going to about a year of
chiropractic school then kind of started
looking at the how much it was gonna
cost would be in about two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars of debt and home
the average income was only about ninety
thousand and so I kind of made the call
to say well let's hang this up and head
over and start working at paying things
off so Wow
yeah it was a tough call for me yeah but
I felt like it was the best choice for
our family and it's been awesome well
you've certainly cleaned up a mess here
without a doubt now you
set to go do whatever you want to do
right right now you just got to figure
out what that game plan is because
you're right that 250 versus 90 is and
that ratio doesn't work whether it's in
cash or whether it's in debt it doesn't
matter I mean that's that's not an awful
heavy expenditure atif or a $90,000 job
yeah you know and so what is your
long-term career goals now honestly okay
cool well good for you guys
well now you're setting a place you can
make some decisions though right and and
you're making good money in the meantime
yeah and provide it for your family and
clean this mess up so what tell me the
story of what happened three and a half
years ago I get the chiropractic as part
of the story but what was the wake-up
call my mom she gave us the home study
Financial Peace University course misma
Sonya okay
it kind of sat on a shelf for about a
year or so yeah picked up the book and
read the book and that's honestly what
kind of got me thinking while we were a
school there and that was kind of a
changing point for me and it was a big
factor in my decision so crystal John
comes and he's been reading this crazy
book and says I may not wanna finish
this what'd you say I was a little upset
at first
bad you did a lot of work to get us over
there mm-hmm
but you know once he started telling me
like you know once we even graduate from
chiropractic school we're still gonna
have to live like college kids that kind
of was like oh oh I don't want to live
like this for another ten years after
I'm done with college mm-hmm so we
started you know looking at other jobs
and the you know oil-filled and and I
actually started reading parts of your
book and I usually don't like reading
books like that I'm not I'm the free
spirit sure
but your book was actually really
entertaining and it caught my interest
well thank you and it was probably the
first like book that wasn't like a
fictional book that actually read and so
you really you cut my free spirit
interest and that helped me get on board
and I guess part of it was we live in a
really remote area in Montana
there's kind of not a lot there so we
wanted the opportunity to take Financial
Peace University with the group but that
opportunity wasn't there and so I got
with Glenn and we set up a class in
dental office that my brother-in-law now
works in and and my wife's brother is
the office manager there uh-huh and so
we set up a class there and started
teaching the class and it took us about
the second time through the class to get
rid of you United in gizelle intense
uh-huh
but after that we really started getting
after it and that question was nothing
like teaching something to make you do
it right exactly I said that yeah you
can't you can't you start feeling
hypocritical if you're not leaning in
yeah for teachers you better be learnin
I've done the same thing with different
different subjects well congratulations
how does it feel now it was amazing
actually yeah we filmed it was pretty
surreal just to not have still almost
every paycheck we get even though we
have the budget we know what we're doing
with the money if you still have that
thought of what do we do with our money
now because there's no we kind of our
stimulant stimulus-response society so
when something comes at us we respond so
like a bill comes in the mail you pay
the bill if you don't have that stimulus
then what do you do so that's where the
budget comes in and that additional
income allocation form exactly and start
setting some goals for owning some nice
things and taking some trips and
investing into the next career field if
there's a different one and so on
exactly yeah like this trip has been
amazing we've been talking about it from
the start of becoming debt-free and we
went down to San Antonio Texas and up to
Waco Texas and down to New Orleans and
now here so it's you visited some good
cities yeah and nice very fun that's
been a good track cool so how old are
your kids and what are their names
we have Oakley who's six and Bentley
who's four and Ruby who is a year old
okay come on Cole they're bringing them
in to the end of the shot for the folks
watching on the TV app
on our website this will be Ruby okay
there's Ruby and she loves her mommy
right now happy yeah absolutely this is
Balian Oakley so have they been
practicing their debt-free scream how we
practice a little bit in the car a
little bit okay so we'll see how we do
they're young yeah it's all good
well congratulations y'all I'm very
proud of you Congrats a huge
accomplishment eighty-seven thousand
dollars in three and a half years making
80 up to a hundred and thirty a move a
change in careers a whole different
track on life but completely free count
it down let's hear a great debt free
scream three well done you guys very
very very well done you know why most
people don't win they don't bother you
have to bother it to be intentional
never again as American Express gonna
call my house and ask my wife why she
would stay with a man that won't pay his
bills
you